you
hi everyone is Jerry in December of 2017
the chess world was introduced to
something very special
google's deepmind AI alpha zero with
that came the release of ten games
played between alpha 0 and stockfish 8
at the time the world's very best chess
engine fast forward about a year
December 6 2018 was when the full peer
reviewed alpha 0 paper was published in
science magazine I'll have a link to
that in the description
additionally 210 more games were
released that is for me at least a huge
gift if you have any interest in
improving your chest my tip from now on
may very well be to observe alpha zero
in action there's a lot to take away
from these games I have only skimmed
through over a hundred of them I will be
revisiting them looking at them much
more thoroughly but there are if you
have a keen eye for the game there are
patterns to know from its play it is
almost as if alpha zero is demonstrating
how chess ought to be played it is
really something special so I'm gonna
share one of these games with you right
now alpha zero has white again stockfish
eight and as per usual when I cover
these games I am including stockfish
eight engine throughout even though
there is a stockfish ten no stockfish
eight is the opponent and I wouldn't get
I want to give you as best a sense for
where stockfish eights head was at for
this game even though it's of course not
running on the same hardware throughout
but ok stockfish eight throughout at the
very end we'll have a sense for what
stockfish 10 thinks of this game by way
of a graph so opening wise what do we
have it is a Queen's Indian defense
alpha zero seems to really enjoy this
setup
against the queen's indian defense so
Bishop to b4 we've seen this variation
in past videos I've covered Bishop to d2
and after the bishop drops back to e7
this is noted as the rumen variation
trying to inconvenience the bishop
misplaced the bishop
so no castles on move 7 by alpha zero
stockfish eight castles and no castles
on move yeah no castles on move seven or
eight so this already has me kind of you
know scratching my head some why not
maybe castle in this situation well
maybe you want to go Queen side maybe
there's a reason to keep the rook on h1
maybe white wants to hint at a pawn trio
there is enough support for it at this
moment
okay well the reaction is Knight a6
there will be no Knight B form and black
strikes in the center with c5 d5 is the
reply we've seen this advance before in
past games between these two and I
believe in nearly every case it was
played as a pawn sacrifice not the case
in this Kim pawn takes it is now not met
with white circling into the newly
weakened f5 square as a result as a
result of blacks last capture but rather
alpha0 ghost fishing looking for a
tactic on h7 leaving the night out for
bait eventually h6 will be in there but
there will be a hook pawn on h4
additionally d5 is now hit a few times
okay from here 97 there is no other
great square for the night if B 4 isn't
there H 4 first usually H 4 is played
only after H 6 okay move order is
switched this night is poison so just to
demonstrate why this is the case let's
just say alpha zero castles in this
position why is the knight poison let's
find out yeah having the H file
completely opened is too much especially
when we have opposite sides castling the
material investment is nothing for white
the open lines is most important
can't go too far with the nitrite queen
h7 formate if the knight jumps in the
center Knight takes d5 and there's no
there's no holding this position the
knight is hit twice
so Knight is poison and pop quiz to you
after h6 alpha zero plays pawn takes
pawn or Knight takes pawn on d5 which
one would you play feel free to pause
the video okay
this was an instructive moment for me
alpha zero played Knight takes d5 so I'd
like to elaborate some on this move why
was it instructive for me to see this
well here's some of the reasoning I
would use to go forward with pawn takes
I might say to myself well I now have
some space I have a pawn in Black's
house and I would prefer to play with
more pieces for minor pieces a piece
well oh I might also add my knight on c3
is better than your knight on c7 c7 yeah
third rank Knight better than your
second rank Knight and that's probably
right around where my thoughts would end
on this decision another point we can
make with Knight takes d5 white is okay
with exchanging a piece in order to open
up a new square for the bishop on c3 so
this earlier point with the bishop
playing to b4 to provoke Bishop to d2
alright Bishop b4 Bishop d2 and then the
bishop returned to e7 it's almost like
white is trying to say you know what you
actually helped me because now I'm only
one move away from getting on this main
diagonal I and I will soon be pointing
at the heart of the kingside structure
white is okay with playing with just
three minor pieces instead of four c3 is
a strong post for the bishop
okay from here d6 the night is still
poison another instructed moment move 15
still no decision for the king certainly
don't want a Castle kingside because you
need to keep this you know these three
pieces are all linked Queen rook and
Knight they all need to you know focus
on that h7 square so you know castling
the knight can actually be captured now
there's no no rook around
why is a four instructive to me well for
one it is looking to restrict blacks
majority there will be no quick b5 in
this position if white immediately goes
to c3 okay at some point I believe black
will be nearby with b5 and maybe B for
disrupting the bishops post on c3 maybe
kicking it off of the diagonal the main
diagonal what I like about a4 is that it
not only restricts black in some way but
maybe hints at a rook lift rook a3
swinging over to the Kings side who
knows the weakened square b4 as a result
of this last move that's not something
that could be taken advantage of alright
if there was a night that was able to
get to that square I would think twice
about playing a four but it is simply
not the case here so no great downside
with a four flexible keeping options
open no quick Bishop c3 maybe the bishop
would be in the way of that little rook
maneuver just throwing some things out
there trying to note some differences
with the moves in the move order okay in
this game a four on board Queen d7
Bishop c3 only now this is played with a
threat knock out the knight sweep in
there for me there's only one defender
there on h7 so how does black parry this
rook to e8 this
instructive moment nice way to organize
the pieces this is clearing a square for
the King to run should the knight be
captured now and then the Queen sweeps
in here the King can step here and if
white goes deep white is going to be in
deep trouble here right the Queen is hit
and the knight is hit black would go on
to win the King will slip away
the knight will be lost so no Bishop
takes Knight here this is a good defense
no pawn advances is this going to be bad
I also know yeah the knight could even
jump into e6 pawn takes Knight Queen
takes pawn okay so in the game rook to
e8 rook ft8
Queen side castles only now no b5 in
this position it is being suggested
right now b5 the move played in the game
is Bishop to d8 let's have a quick look
at b5 and how play might develop after
this capture and Queen captures white
can continue with suggesting and g4
possibly hinting at a capture and then a
quick g5 that might not that may not be
long off so let's say rook to b8 yeah
there is a knight takes f7 and then a g5
advance this Knight is basically the
glue for blacks King side so okay from
here Bishop to d8
efore I think given time white is ready
to launch a bunch of pawns on the
kingside this is a majority a 5 vs 4 and
F 4 e 5 give the knight a kick sweep in
for Queen h7 Knight g4 in this position
now after E 4 was play the queen is not
observing h7 is this a moment where the
knight can be captured no it's still not
a point that it could be captured
because look at this position
this beautiful quark grip kills at least
three of the black pieces and being down
a night well how valuable is that night
any anyhow an h7 the Open File outweighs
this Knight e5 is nearby you can see a
doubling on the H file it's gonna turn
out very bad for team black so it's
still poison
Knight g4 in the game Bishop h3 the
knight is captured now materials pick
back up taking advantage of this pin
with f3 f5 takes takes and an hour
reposition of the bishop eyeing up a
skewer and well black does well not to
defend against Bishop to b4 with a six
because having this line open up will be
too much this King is running way short
on squares so G takes h4 the bishop is
around to watch over this square so the
rook is not able to see these points in
blacks camp
Bishop b5 that is a secure but we do not
have this win of the rook keep in mind
this is alpha zero just knows the rules
of the game learning from experience
self play and so doesn't know Bishop is
worth three rook is worth five piece
play seeing the bishop as maybe a bit
more valuable then the rook in this
position goes for something else better
things to do G takes H for this pawn
lives and maybe at some stage can be a
battering ram against the Kings side
getting in a pawn break h6 extending the
scope of the bishop now in this position
Bishop f6 was played I want to have a
look at one variation here suppose the
rook is saved suppose Rick f8 is played
how might play continue what we can have
is rook D to g1 looking to track down
this pawn and key in on the g7 square
and if it is defended with Bishop to c8
well now this rook is that much further
off from contributing to the Kings side
which is where the action is going to
take place at this stage so play can
follow let me just put some variation in
there the King can get pulled out
checked in the center starts to collapse
with E 5 and yeah you really start to
see the bishops knifing in I believe now
not Bishop c6 straight away Queen to e4
and after Bishop to f6 there's d6 with
an attack against the rook this is too
much for black to parry this pawn is
running really fast how much further do
we go here
check King to h8 and you can already
promote here we're getting really fancy
right Bishop takes Queen game over rook
takes Queen thank you for the Bishop it
can collapse really fast there is a pawn
break and that D pawn can run so in the
game we have Bishop to f6 rook to f1 I'm
not
I really can't wrap my head around the
reason behind rook on h2 f1 versus rook
deed f1 I can't assign a good reason for
that it's not to say that there isn't
one it's just I don't I can't really put
my finger on that one what follows is
rip to f8 Bishop takes Bishop pawn takes
so the king is that much more vulnerable
now
less pawn defense and the rook is
inactive now just staring at its own
pawn on a closed file we can say no
great activity for the black rooks or
Bishop and yeah black is only playing on
two ranks in this position and it's very
difficult to defend g4 overextended and
soon it will fall so Queen g7 Bishop to
e2 and Queen to h5 if black tries to
hang on to this pawn that's not really
hanging on to the pawn because you can
capture straight away with rook to g1
and the bishop will be one next white is
crashing through on the G you file so
Queen h6 white doubles g3 that pawn is
hunted no good way to save it
jeetu still queen g3 with check picking
the pawn up next so the King gets on the
H file tries to hide behind this pawn
Queen takes g3 and now the focus is just
on consolidating some firstiy for
tucking the King away plenty of time to
make these tidying up type of moves King
safety yeah
there's no getting at the white king in
this position Bishop d7 instructive
moment I think white could go ahead and
crash through on f6 right now but there
is no rush in the game we have h5 if
white goes forward with this let's just
have a look at this variation
in the end there's bishop takes a four
and if Rick takes d6 there's c4 and
black will be winning the e pun alright
Bishop takes c4 there's rook takes e4
and if Bishop c2 we exchange bishops and
go here this is still apparently very
good for white but white wants to
basically get these two pawns and hang
on to these two guys in the center have
two connected passed pawns so in the
game we have h5 upon that is poison all
right rook h4 would hit with the skewer
also if Bishop takes a four in this
position we have the cool move e5 right
this pawn is ready to be passed and the
bishop is hit so no bishop takes a for a
very passive move rook to f8 if either
rook moves then this pawn could fall
next bishop to see to everything is
defended the bishop is now on a
protected square perfect coordination
here by white and black is basically in
Zook swung what do you do here in the
game bishop te 8 is played
we have rook to f3 basically a little
waiting move and black is gonna have to
give up a pawn shortly doing something
else at this stage let's say after rook
to f3 a rookie 7 was played if the
bishop returns to this square white can
focus on the g6 square now rook g3 into
g6 so that's going to be a problem the
bishop on EI is there to watch over that
square so in this game the rook backing
up to f3
rook to e7 also I believe another point
is that if the bishop goes to this
square you can have Queen to h2 and this
can be a great bother having the Queen
put pressure on d6
now that the rook isn't on f4 okay well
in this game
rookie 7 is played and only at this
point is white go ahead and crash
through capturing on f6 and we have this
ending where white is simply going to
keep two connected passed pawns we know
how valuable they can be at this point
it's only a matter of improving the King
and pushing the passed pawns so let's
see how that plays out breaking down the
structure on the Queen side you know if
this pawn lives it gets to a6 and I know
that a pawn will fall and that guy will
run fast so B takes a5 King D to some
repositioning and here you go the pawns
there's no stopping it really after E 5
that's the final move of this game black
at this stage resigns no good solution
here the threat is to play e6 e7 and
then promote right if here this is
hitting with tempo this would not be a
solution for black there is no draw here
would be a draw if you can let's say
exchange this last pawn but you're not
getting that last pawn all these pawns
will soon fall some other variation that
interferes with a six and a seven let's
say Bishop to b3 you can take upon for
starters or immediately going for this
who cares about the a pawn this is a
pretty serious threat rook d8 and Bishop
to f5 this is a cool sequence
this whole position right here keeps
black frozen there's no way black and
disrupted this formation of the white
pieces and this pawn restricts all black
pawns and the white King could simply
improve so just planning out some moves
here how am i play continue black had
only shuffle at this point maybe push
once the king is here there's a pretty
serious threat black has to try
something fancy like that and run rook
takes here's threatening mate this is
threatening mate it can only be parried
in so many ways Bishop takes pawn
in white would go on to win this
position something like this eventually
you push through plenty of ways to do it
though but I thought that that was a
neat little way to tie black down but
the rook on c8 and a little diagonal of
pieces there but II five in this one is
the final move of this game and
stockfish resigns this is when the game
was and this game ended after move 49 an
instructive one another game out of a
Queen's Indian but a little bit
different there that night h4 move know
we had a fishing pole in this one with
Knight to g5 that caused some
compromises in black structure and they
were eventually exploited those
weaknesses so let's have a look at the
tale the tape on this one and once more
we have this here as dock fish 10 now
this is the evaluation at the moment
stock fish 10 is the world's best at the
time of this upload this is what I had
to say throughout for this game and yeah
certainly some instructive moments for
this game the night d5 capture early on
for me playing with three minor pieces
was instructive having that c3 square
and also that a4 move right not being
too quick to commit the king in that
position type interesting play to be
sure at the end of the day inaccuracies
one for alpha zero where does it
consider there is an inaccuracy
right here where it's basically already
winning age five was played probably at
that moment where you could crash
through on f6 but there was some tidying
up type of moves played before crashing
through their stockfish eight apparently
has four inaccuracies three mistakes
fourteen average sent upon loss
considered for alpha zero and 24 for
stock fish eight starfish the fishing
pole is too strong
you